Albert Einstein put forward one of the most
profound explanations of the universe in his
general theory of relativity. It wasn’t
a complete picture of the universe, but NOW
science might be one step closer.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
There are two theories that govern mostly
everything in our universe. Einstein’s theory
of relativity accounts for the big stuff,
the way planets move around a sun. His theory
says that spacetime is geometric and that
large objects warp spacetime. Think of a bowling
ball on a sheet. As the bowling ball moves
around the sheet, it bends the sheet around
it. That’s how large objects warp geometric
spacetime.
Quantum theory explains all the weirdness
that occurs when things get very very small,
how a photon can be both a particle and wave.
One of the strangest things about quantum
theory involves an idea called entanglement.
It’s an idea Einstein wasn’t too fond
of, he called it “spooky action at a distance”.
For most of the past century, these two theories
seemed at odds with each other. If gravity
governed everything then these small particles
shouldn’t behave that way. And the puzzle
of how these two pieces fit together to describe
our universe has been one of the biggest frustrations
in physics for the past 100 years or so. Thought
it’s not for lack of trying. Dozens of theories
have been put forward, but not satisfactory
enough.
Until one. After repeated rejections from
journals, Physicist Mark Van Raamsdonk described
his theory in an essay published in the journal
General Relativity and Gravitation. So in
one neat theory he ties up most of the loose
ends between the two dominating theories in
physics. He explained that entanglement could
be the basis for geometric gravity.
His idea considers two model universes, one
is called anti-de Sitter space (AdS). AdS,
also called the bulk, is similar to ours in
which there’s 3 dimensions, it’s filled
with quantum particles, and it obeys Einstein's
laws of physics. But it doesn’t expand or
contract. The other universe, called the boundary
is only 2 dimensions, is filled with elementary
particles and doesn’t contain gravity. According
to physicist Juan Maldacena, the boundary
and the bulk are equivalent, they follow the
same physics. Some compare the two universes
to a balloon. The thin membrane of latex is
the 2D boundary and the air inside makes up
the bulk. Or others have compared it to a
hologram. Where information is encoded on
a 2D chip and projected onto 3D space.
But by using the boundary to describe what’s
going on in the bulk, theoretical physicists
could now create calculations without using
pesky gravity. And a whole new field of physics
took off.
But the question remained... how are those
two universes connected?
Well that’s where entanglement comes in.
Entanglement is a pretty fascinating concept
in physics and to be honest, one I don’t
completely understand. Entanglement when two
particles are linked through an unseen pathway,
some researchers consider this pathway to
be the same thing as a worm hole. When particles
are connected in this way, a particle can
affect the way the other particle spins, even
if there is a vastness of space between them.
So when when observing one particle we know
the state of another. And while this strange
behavior dominates most of the weirdness we
call quantum physics, it could also be responsible
for space-time.
According to Raamsdonk “Space-time is just
a geometrical picture of how stuff in the
quantum system is entangled.” As particles
become entangled with each other they form
a network that looks like a tree branching
off into many different directions. This network
is called tensor networks. And according to
Raamsdonk, these networks connect the boundary
and the bulk. Think of these connections like
scaffolding, holding up the boundary membrane.
If entanglement is reduced to zero, these
connections are gone, and the bulk is pulled
apart. So entanglement is responsible for
the existence of space-time.
So I must caution that this is theoretical
physics and most of these discoveries have
only played out in mathematical equations
for model universes, not necessarily our own.
So while some research does support this idea,
I’d say more research is needed.
So are you curious for more theoretical physics?
I bet you are!
What about that whole holographic universe
thing?
Well Trace and Ian have the spooky scoop in
this episode right here.